Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm deep in the heart of the
Alaskan Wilderness and for the next four
days I'm building my shelters camping
catching my dinner exploring glaciers
and having a great time come along for
the ride it's going to be a great video
[Music]
well there goes my ride
beautiful
well I'm Gonna Leave the kayak here and
go look for a campsite
foreign
the first thing I'm going to do is
explore a little bit
well there's plenty of wood
looks like a coyote's been walking up
and down this beach
keep finding tons of these little
skeletons they feel really light like
they belong to a bird
a little sea urchin
it's a fish jaw look at all his teeth
that's the top half of a beaver jaw
look what I just found
those are bear paw prints right there
not sure what kind of bear it is but
this is where I want to build my
campsite
well I walked about two miles round trip
down the beach looking for a spring or
creek didn't find anything I've got
about four liters of water and that's
enough for today and tomorrow but
probably not enough for all four days
but right now I've got to focus on
building a shelter it's getting late
foreign
thank you
all right I got a camp set up and not a
moment too soon it's getting dark
with the Rocks behind the fire and the
canvas behind me this is really toasty
which is good because it's gotten chilly
outside I could see my breath I knew I'd
be getting to this spot kind of late so
I packed a pretty simple meal
got some uh
got some cured salami
and I got some smoked salmon and pilot
bread I caught some silver salmon a
couple weeks ago and I smoked them up
and then I mixed the smoked salmon in
with brie honey walnuts and garlic
for dessert I have chocolate covered
macadamia nuts
got myself some blisters right there and
there
it's late and I've got a lot to do
tomorrow I'm gonna put up the camera
hopefully we won't have any bears
joining us tonight
see you guys in the morning
oh good morning
it's cold outside
oh that's gorgeous
oh before I get the fire started and
start cooking breakfast I think I want
to complete the fire ring
foreign
a couple perfectly shaped stones
[Applause]
that one's promising
I wouldn't mind another one of those
I'm sitting here finishing breakfast and
I can see A Flock of Seagulls diving on
Bait fish right there
maybe I need to rig up the rod
[Applause]
just checking my bait and I reeled in a
flesh eating starfish
all right we go put him back
[Music]
that's an eagle feather that's from a
young bald eagle
but a surf fishing wasn't really paying
off and we've got a few hours before
high tide so I'm hiking back to the
kayak to see if we can go do some kayak
fishing while I'm at it I want to keep
an eye out for a water source I only got
about a liter and a half of fresh water
left so I've got to go look for water
foreign
tell you what I was just thinking I wish
I had a hat I hope there's not lies in
it
we got the bald eagle up there
oh those are such a big bird
all right we got some water oh
[Music]
that's uh that's brackish there's
definitely a fair amount of salt water
in that so this right here is a tidal
River it changes Direction based on
whether the Tide's coming in or out so I
think I'm gonna put my kayak in and
catch a ride out into the bay see if we
can't catch some fish
stop and do a little bit of lunch before
I get on the kayak
movie covered mango
we let the current take me down the
river a little fish a little bit in the
lagoon When the tide switches we'll
catch the current back
sure nice not having a paddle but I'm
hearing an ominous roaring noise down
that direction
we got some pretty serious Breakers here
but if I flip over in this I'm gonna go
hypothermic immediately I mean there's
literally ice washing up on the beach
this water is so cold it hurts to put
your hand in it but I've been sitting
here for a few minutes and I haven't
seen any breakers off to the left so I
think that's the trick
crap
oh that was a lot crazier than I
intended yeah I may not be going back
that way
oh this iceberg's making crazy noises it
sounds like it's being deep fried the
ocean water is about 40 45 degrees and
so it's substantially warmer than the
ice
oh that is cool
I want to see if I can catch myself a
fish for dinner and usually the
fishing's better when you're fishing
underneath Cliffs as opposed to Beach
thank you
oh hello
Liz it's a little baby salmon
oh
I got the little baby silver won't fill
me up but he'll taste just fine well
we'll keep him
oh look at this count green
nice little kelp Greenly
oh there we go
oh little baby kelp grilling
oh
another kill Greenlee
foreign
Ling aren't horrible but I like other
fish better and I think I'm gonna catch
something
that is what we want
there we go look at that black bass
where there's one of those there's
usually more
oh oh we got a big one we got a nice
fish
oh
look at that
I believe this is a copper rockfish
I'm gonna go ahead and put him back
you're only allowed to keep one of those
per day
oh there we go
oh another Black Mass you allowed three
of these per day but I'm not gonna eat
both of these suckers I got enough food
oh there we go oh look at that beauty
what a feisty fish
little Puffin swimming right by me over
there
another black bass I could have limited
out
there we go
another big black bass
well the fishing's been pretty awesome
I've got dinner and I've lost count how
many fish I caught but I'm getting
thirsty and water's getting really low I
need to go find a source of drinking
water
I'm so glad to see this water
[Applause]
that is all the water we had left
this is the best water filter system it
just pulls it through with gravity
I got four liters of drinking water and
three liters I can filter later ah that
feels good to have water I've been
stressing about that
[Applause]
dang some of those waves are popping up
six feet tall
I'm just gonna Portage the kayak over
this little spit of land over here
that way I can avoid all that craziness
over there
we go we're back in the river and we're
rapidly moving the opposite direction we
were a few hours ago
man that current is ripping if I were to
stay on this River it would take me to a
lake full of icebergs and an enormous
Glacier that's calving into the lake I
really want to go see that but that'll
have to wait for tomorrow
foreign
well that wasn't great
well there we go we caught dinner and
survived to tell the tale
it was a little cold last night and it's
supposed to get even colder as the week
goes on so I'm gonna bust out my stove
[Music]
oh
I think it's time to cook some fish
and a little bit of maple syrup
there we go put it in the smoke but out
of the Heat
got a little bread flour in these here
walking miles on those rocks with these
boots has just been killing my feet
[Applause]
that is some beautiful fillets right
there
[Music]
a little pepper smoked paprika
ticket and mole here
[Music]
there we go
you got chicken and mole
green Hatch Chiles and lots of Rockfish
some salsa
Rockfish is such a firm white meat
really good
oh that was good
[Applause]
for dessert I'm gonna finish off my
bread with a little bit of honey I don't
know what it is but there are a few
things better than warm bread and honey
ah that was good
oh
I will see you guys in the morning
good morning
putting this stove in last night was the
best idea ever oh it's so toasty idea
oh pancakes are hard to beat
I guess technically this is breakfast in
bed
nice
okay
foreign
's done
it's tiny but good
well despite the weather I really want
to go see that glacier
this is the bald eagles footprint look
at the size comparison to my hand
from one Talon to the other that's
probably eight inches
oh darn I missed the tide
it's heading the wrong way I might be
able to get up against the current we'll
see
in the middle of the river the current's
moving faster than I can paddle but
maybe if I stick to the sides I can
sneak Upstream
oh my hands are so cold
all right
check out that eagle
a bunch of pink salmon right there look
at that
I think I made it to the lake that feeds
the river
now it's hard to see with all this fog
but there's an enormous Glacier falling
into this Lake somewhere over there I
just gotta see if I can find a way
through all this ice
oh that'll buff out I gotta be careful
going in between these icebergs some of
these weigh more than buildings and as
the tide goes up and down they're gonna
shift and move around this clear water
can disappear or worse yet you can get
squished in between two big icebergs
all right
this place is just full of seals and sea
otters I've seen like 20 of them
this ice pack goes on forever
ice it comes from the bottom of the
glacier is super compressed and has that
really cool blue color
the fog lifted and I can see the face of
the glacier the tide switches in about
an hour and a half and it's taken me
three hours to get here so I better get
heading back
foreign
I know I'm hungry when I'm double
fisting it
full of that kayaking wore me out that
was about five hours
thank you
well it's almost dinner time and I got
some bread dough left over so I think
I'm gonna make a Bushcraft bread oven
[Applause]
we got the oven stuff full of wood got
the dough rising in the pot
all right
just stick it over here and let it rest
there we go
oh is there anything better than warm
fresh bread yes warm fresh bread with
honey butter oh
that was so good oh the crust is so
crispy on this thing
oh I'm getting so full
I've got a belly full of warm bread and
it's nice and cozy in here
I'm gonna just kind of take it easy I'm
sore after all that kayaking
away in the summer
signed a number
she worked in the description though
here we go
nice little wooden spoon
well I think I made a little bit of a
mess here
it's been a fun relaxing evening but
I've got to get to bed I've got to get
up early in the morning I'll see you
guys then
oh good morning
I've got to hurry up and get packed
[Applause]
I hate packing up in the rain all of my
gear is soaked and dirty
all right
now I just gotta wait for my ride look
at that there's a whole bunch of seals
right out there trying to catch pink
salmon
oh there's my boat
[Music]
whoa I don't don't need my shower for
the month now
you doing
oh well guys I hope you enjoyed this
adventure if you want to see more
camping videos from the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel make sure to check out
our camping Adventure playlist and don't
forget to click subscribe alright guys
we'll see you next video If you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching